you
good day everyone this is Jack Van Horn
from the university of southern
california and the big data to knowledge
a training coordinating Center and I'd
like to welcome you to this our final in
our series of guide to the fundamentals
of data science seminar series to wear
this today we're very delighted to have
dr. Patricia Flatley Brennan director of
the National Library of Medicine and
interim associate NIH director for data
science speaking on data science at the
NIH current state and future directions
we're very delighted to have dr. Brennan
who is the former Lillian L Bolden
Boscombe professor at the School of
Nursing and College of Engineering at
the University of wisconsin-madison
where she led the living environments
laboratory at the Wisconsin institutes
for discovery develops computer link in
an electronic network designed to reduce
isolation improve self-care amongst
health home care patients and directed
heart care directed health design she
has a long list of accolades and her CV
must be pages and pages and chapters
long in particular most recently she has
been the director of the National
Library of Medicine since August of 2016
and recently as of January of 2017 took
on the role of the interim associate NIH
director for data science the adze
office that many of you are familiar
with and as as part of that she is in a
leadership position for the bd2k
Enterprise many of which you participate
in so we're very delighted to get some
insights from her about the current
state of data science at the NIH what
future directions hold through data
science at the NIH for biomedical
research progress in all manner of data
mining and computation and informatics
etc so we're very delighted to have dr.
Brennan and I would like to ask you that
if you have any questions for dr. Brown
and please use the GoToWebinar a
question submission feature and you can
submit your questions and then about 10
minutes before the hour we'll take those
questions I'll read them off to her and
she'll get a chance to answer so without
further delay dr. Brennan
thank you so much for joining us thanks
very much and I appreciate the kind
introduction
I'm saying all of you for taking time
out of your day today if it says
beautiful where you are as it is here in
Washington you're missing a bright sunny
but rather hot day outside to
participate in this last of the big data
data science seminars held of now for
almost four year I want to say how happy
I am to be a part of this seminar series
and how glad I am to be at this point in
time certainly there have been some
notable speakers that have gone ahead of
me bringing you both technical solutions
I hope and new perspectives and thinking
about data and data science my role
today is to accomplish four things with
you first I want to give you an update
on what's going on at NIH with data
science there's many things it's a
vibrant active part of our mission
second I want to provide you with some
of my views and perspectives on data
science so you can understand how I'm
approaching this challenge and perhaps
guide me with your ideas of how to make
sure we create a robust infrastructure
for discovery third I'm going to explain
our near-term inand at your efforts in
both the intramural NIH campus level
investments as well as our national
investments in data science and finally
and I hope to actually save even more
time than the ten minutes at the end to
get your thoughts and ideas about how
the NIH can facilitate data science
data-driven discovery and the clinical
practice and health improvement of our
country based on investments in data
driven resources I want you to think
about what kind of services would be
needed in the future what kind of
supports do you need are you looking
forward to certain types of granting
programs certain types of methodological
issues who would be thinking about
workforce development those kinds of
resources I would very much appreciate
your guidance on and I'm going to ask
crystal and the organizers if they can
record all of the comments that come in
if we don't get to address all of them
in our conversation today let me begin
by taking you to the end why why do we
actually want to invest in data science
we believe that fundamentally data
science is a pathway to discovery as a
new and essential pathway to discovery
and along that pathway there are
opportunities there are challenges and
there's a need for some direction the
idea that data with data drives
discovery is a fundamental shift not
simply in the methods we use but in the
way we conduct research and at NIH this
commitment is very strong and it begins
at the highest level of leadership dr.
Collins is personally invested in how to
create the proper infrastructure for
data science the bd2k program that was
familiar to most of you over the years
it began as a as an inquiry spurned on
by the enormous amounts of data being
generated through genomic and proteomic
studies in the late 90s and early 2000s
a realization that we needed to enable
biomedical sciences to capitalize on the
data being generated by research
communities and so the bd2k program
launched through after a series of
workshops held that met with many
different sectors many different
stakeholders and came to focus on the
idea that we needed to provide training
infrastructure we need to stimulate all
types of research in new areas about
data we need to simulate basic
methodological inquiry as well as
investment in the infrastructure needed
to support data and what you see on the
screen here is our homepage for data
science at NIH and I call your attention
to the the bar at the bottom which
describes the data science community the
big data to knowledge process and the
Commons the data science community is
broader than anyone ever expected
bringing not only genomics-based
researchers but also people with
advanced analytics machine learning and
artificial intelligence specialists even
bringing in engineers and computer
scientists and designing new data models
new kinds of recent resources and
storage press strategies in addition the
library science community has
increasingly large role as part of the
data science community with their skills
and curation standard setting
dissemination and collection management
we organize a lot of the thinking around
data science under the concept of a
commons and we'll return to this phrase
several times I know you've had other
discussions about it earlier throughout
this year from the perspective of the
NIH at this point in times the Commons
is both a concept as well as a physical
space and I'll be talking about some of
the work that's being done to set up the
NIH Commons the idea is the Commons
provides a safe harbor for data to be
stored but also a pathway for dated to
be accessed and used we envision the
data Commons is not only serving a
reserved apposite ori for data but also
as a suite of services resources for
modeling for curation and for
establishing a good catalog of data and
information let me speak to you
specifically about the bd2k program
right now for that's what brought a lot
of people into this process as you you
know 3d 2k program was intended to be
about one hundred and twenty five
hundred thirty million dollar initiative
per year over about an eight-year period
and we're about halfway through this
period at this time with the departure
of Phil Bourne and the reorganization of
the associate director of data science
office we've had many discussions with
the NIH leadership about how to make
sure we're getting the yield and value
out of the NIH investment in bid that
big data to knowledge Commons the goods
knowledge project excuse me we
anticipate that this project will
continue from now through its intended
target date of 2021 and the project is
fully funded through this period of time
and yet there are changes that are being
made those changes are summarized in a
blog post that we provided on February
the 23rd they link to the blog post is
is on the screen in front of you but
essentially let me summarize what's in
that blog post first we have a the
beauty to Kane program resources were
designed to provide extramural support
that is all of NIH
support for data discovery data curation
and data management we remain committed
to all existing programs and so they
will be funded that they're originally
intended level all programs that will
act that are active as this was as of
January but continues through now all
programs that are active will be funded
through the endpoint of their their
period of time many of them winding up
by August of 2018 we added one new
funding a new program funding this
spring and that was an initiative on
curation that had been released prior to
the the planned pivoting of the bd2k
program and that was that the
announcements about those funding of the
funding of those new projects will come
out during this summer they are
specifically targeting innovations in
curation including some very exciting
uses of natural language processing to
facilitate automated curation we are
also at this time considering and
putting together the think tank within
NIH to plan for future needs including
training research infrastructure and
policy development what's important
about this is during the process of
pivoting from the extramural program to
the next phase of bd2k we recognize that
we have a rapidly growing amount of data
that still lacks a safe place for
storage so during this two-year period
of time we are investing more in
creating NIH based resources for our
high-value data sets and for access for
researchers to begin to compute on those
data sets I'll return to that comp those
comments in a few minutes after we talk
about in general the process of
discovery through data but remember I'm
hoping that you will continue to jot
down your thoughts and think about how
the NIH can foster data-driven discovery
as you perceive it from your own work
place in your own work career but let's
pause for a moment and think about where
discoveries originated from and why the
NIH should be investing in creating an
infrastructure for discovery early
discoveries of the Health Sciences were
originated through the process of
experience an individual clinician
Keillor worked with a patient or the
person in need made observations about
what happened the response hopefully an
improvement because of additional
sunshine certain herbs or maybe certain
kinds of medication these processes of
experience were translated to written
documents and the pathway for discovery
became a one-time experience with an
individual shared in a narrative or
heuristic fashion as we moved to the
late 18 early 19th century we began to
see the embracing of experimental design
as a pathway to discovery experimental
design had lots of advantages it allowed
us to to focus specifically on
phenomenon to may be discerned a pathway
that explain why certain phenomenon
occurred in a certain fashion or did not
occur it let us determine which
techniques worked better than others
increasingly experiments also brought
about a perspective on science that
allowed for excluding or controlling for
variability in the process it was being
observed by ensuring that careful
procedures were followed by ensuring
that that certain variable certain
aspects of the phenomena were
highlighted and others were not attended
to and precision in measurement and
understanding allowed for a process of
discovery this philosophy was a very
what I would call particular istic
approach to discovery that essentially
requires the investigator to design a
priori an experiment that had the
appropriate variables the appropriate
manipulations and the appropriate
controls and allowing and learning
through prior studies for example or
through a study of the literature what
aspects of the phenomenon needed to be
attended to and what could be ignored
part of the value of experimentation was
its narrowness of focus but part of the
limitation was its narrowness of focus
and increasingly over time experiments
generated more and more data as we moved
into the 60s in the in the US and around
the world computation became an
important complement to the experimental
design computation now let freed us from
being too overly restrict on the number
of variables that could be observed and
analyzed at the same
time and allowed for an increasing
augmentation not only of the research
process but of the cognition of the
individual who is trying to understand
some Naaman on and plot the pathway
through we now are moving into what I
think of as the fourth generation of
discovery processes and that is data
driven discovery here we are freed from
the constraints that experiments once
required us to adhere to that is a
limitation and the number of variables
or limitation the consideration of what
aspects need to be considered and what
it brings us to us the ability to
understand phenomenon in context in much
greater detail the challenge of managing
this information as a process of
discovery is going to require changes in
the way we think about the substrate the
infrastructure to support discovery when
we when we think of a data-driven era of
discovery we're envisioning data as a
substrate that is both generated by
experiments and observations and then
becomes subsequently later on the
substance that future discoveries are
rests on so we see a process here of
accelerating discovery activities
conducted once content data that can be
reused many times
fundamentally data-driven discovery
rests on two aspects data and
computation I'm not going to go into too
much depth about the data the fair
principles of data I'm sure they're well
familiar to the audience that we're
speaking but for those who who may be
less familiar with them I let me just
say stay forward that the there is
acceptance around the world that for
data driven discovery we must have a
quality of data that makes sure that
that that those that are findable are
accessible or interoperable and reusable
for data to be findable we need to
attend to the labeling the metadata the
curation of the data to ensure it's it
is locatable through a machine
interaction that begins with making sure
the data are well labeled and catalogued
and described in a way that can be
discovered insuring the data are
accessible is not only a technical
challenge but it's also a challenge of
ensuring that the
and authorization to use datasets is
appropriately managed so the data are
managed in a respected and respectable
fashion interoperability is they that
characteristic that we trust will lead
us to be able to link datasets from more
than one environment from more than one
experiment across several experiments
the interoperability of data requires
the time that data be findable that is
terms be used in a similar and
consistent fashion but also that they be
accessible through platforms that allow
the transmission of analytics as well as
the transmission of the data themselves
fundamentally embedded drive and
discovery the principle of reusability
governs what we do that is we start from
an original experiment moving on to a
recognition that the data generated from
one experiment needs to be placed in a
storage strategy that is accessible to
others but reusability like our other
three characteristics of data is not
simply a technical challenge but it's
also a social challenge reusable data
and discovery driven by reusable data
sets is a shift in the way research has
done and valued primary investigation
often was considered the hallmark of the
best practices of research and secondary
analysis while useful was not often
awarded the same level of respect and
consideration in terms of its value
increasingly we are now realizing that
one single experiment even one that is
very designed in a very complex fashion
engaging a lot of investigators still
doesn't allow us that doesn't yield all
of the findings that the data set
generated in that experiment could yield
and so we now need to think not only how
to make that data reusable but how to
make reusable data-driven discovery
approaches to research as values as
useful for society as our experimental
models computational challenges remain
data science is not simply statistics on
steroids or a bioinformatics with large
groups large sets of data but really
requires us to think about ways we can
bring in new kinds of analytics
one of the values of data-driven
discovery is that we are freed of the
assumptions that must be met in order to
be able to use classic statistics and de
Finetti models we are able now to take
data in its natural form and use that
data in a way to help discover it by
considering different approaches to
analytics and I call your attention to
developments in three areas that I find
particularly promising distributed
analytics machine learning and booms
give me an optimization distributed
analytics allow us to essentially bring
analytic tools to where the data reside
and return the results of analysis to be
compiled and integrated in the fashion
this is a marked departure from our
usual multi-site clinical trials models
where data are collected in one place
and gathered in a second central place
for subsequent analysis distributed
analytics have a power to be able to
look at different phenomenon over time
but importantly also have the promise of
ensuring privacy preservation so the
data themselves are not transported only
the analytics from the data machine
learning strategies particularly deep
learning bring a chance to understand
data from its basic discovery model and
then require a interpretation based on
the frameworks in the series that are
brought by domain science the values of
machine learning is that they are is
lies in the fact that the the patterning
that is it success is not constrained by
certain underlying assumptions of the
data but rather can be brought forward
based on the existence of the data
itself essentially we have a semantic
rediscovery strategy that later requires
interpretation this by way is also one
of the downfalls many machine learning
results are difficult to explain to
domain scientists or clinicians and
therefore require a longer pathway to
explanation optimization is an approach
brought invite from operations research
that allows us to look at pathways
through datasets discovering from the
millions of possible trajectories for
example or the millions of possible
samples that could be drawn which are
the ones that would be most promising
optimization gives us a chance to
approach data in a more principled
fashion
so that we can make the best use of the
analytic powers available for the data
scientists discovery I'm particularly
particular promise in visualization
strategies and two in particular visual
analytics the use of analytical displays
the use of visual displays of data as an
assistance in the process of analysis
and also in depicting results one of the
challenges of data science is that while
it's not restricted to very large data
sets it's often employed in very in the
analysis of very large data sets ones
that are not human can read about or too
large for a human to comprehend and so
the visualization tools allow us the
opportunities to explore these data sets
and again examine bring in human
judgment as needed it's important to
spend a little bit of time talking about
some of the computational challenges for
the management of data we have a great
need to put in place good business
processes that allow for access access
control management and up front and the
attempt to preserve the proper alignment
of the permission to use the data with
the individual choosing to use it
business management processes are also
needed to help us in and to anticipate
the value of the data set in the
potential cost of curation and the the
cost of reuse of data set so we can put
proper pricing strategies in place
another management challenges that we
face is the preservation of the
provenance of analytical strategies the
enormous size of data sets and the teams
working with them often leads us to
having a very confused pipeline and
they've been the increasing reliance on
pipeline approaches to maintaining the
history of the analysis done with its
particular data set will enable us to
discover a more rigorous more reliable
fashion finally maintaining version
control of the data set
I believe presents a particular
challenge that I think the National
Library of Medicine may have some
specific Euler skills to solve one of
the things that we realize is once data
sets are acquired new investigators
bring new enrichment strategies to them
and require and make modifications that
may be well understood by that
individual this brings us a new to us a
need for managing version control for
having the proper tools in place so that
a basic data set remains
tact but the enhancements and enrichment
done by other investigators also may
remain accessible to the community as it
emerges I'd like to talk to now about
where I see the National Library of
Medicine fitting into this process about
three years ago at NIH a study was done
reported to the director of NIH that
said that the National Library of
Medicine should become the epicenter of
data science for the NIH now at the
center has sort of a bad meaning in some
places the center of an earthquake or
the center of destruction and I
certainly hope the National Library of
Medicine does not become the center of
destruction but I do believe with our
long history over almost 200 years of
support for discovery in our country and
around the world the National Library of
Medicine will play an important role in
accelerating data science let me show
you a brief video that will introduce
you to some of the products and services
at the National Library of Medicine
currently Doug is involved and then
we'll talk about how we're going to be
participating in the data driven
discoveries of the future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this video introduce you to some of our
treasures and some of our products I'm
sure you're all familiar with PubMed
many of you probably also use dbgap
our PubMed our citation database is over
twenty six and a half million citations
to the biomedical literature or to
articles around the world and in ads of
almost million citations every year our
resources are also though used by young
children and families around the world
you saw MEDLINE plus you saw the young
the wonderment on a young child is we
heard the voice of a native healer we
preserved healing traditions of the
country we also provide training we also
provide various ways to make sure our
resources are used you might have been
wondering why we show that slide of
malaria and that cup of water with the
bugs in it
we are trying to use our image
processing analysis to provide in the
field detection of of different diseases
so that in under-resourced country we're
able to take the knowledge of the
library
the decision-making process in the
laboratory as quickly as possible so we
do primarily support research but are
our resources driven by the need to
support research are used globally four
million times a day to PubMed Central
300 thousand times a day to dbgap
millions of individuals access our work
and you saw our pathogen detection
process that's now used every day by
public health authorities around the
country trying to determine the exact
nature of an e coli or listeria outbreak
essentially our future builds on our
pasts and we are ready to take
leadership in the area of data science
around the country but let me take you
back to the very first slides you saw we
began indexing in 1838 and from a for
almost 135 years we work to develop an
index of the medical literature so they
could be located and discovered and used
by researchers and clinicians starting
in the 70s we began to digitize our
indexing tools so they could be accessed
and searched and then with the advent of
the Internet in 1984 we began to look at
how our resources could be used by
individuals around the world without
this mediation of a specialist like a
librarian we face the simha so many
similar challenges today with data as we
face in our pet in the past with
managing the literature making sure that
we have access to it making sure our
investigators know how to use it
providing a pathway for people to report
and and and present their findings of
their research so we believe we will be
able to manage and support that do data
driven discoveries I'd like to focus on
five or six key areas that were guiding
our plans and our investment here the
first is the development and
determination of high-value data sets
high-value data sets are did insensitive
that are worthy of preservation because
of the potential for future discovery
from them now high-value data set maybe
it is that likely to be used by a lot of
individuals you can think of the
Framingham study or the gtex resource
that's being developed to the Common
Fund as types of high-value data sets or
the model organism databases but in
addition
sometimes datasets are a high value
because they're unique and not able to
be done able to be replicated we have
the process of determining high value
data that occurs at multiple times in
the research process first of course at
the point of inception of the original
research that creates the data set it's
worthy to think about what might the
future life of that data set be how long
will it be useful under what
circumstances that will help guide
subsequent decisions about it
secondly at the closing of a research
process which is the point at which
money the curation decisions are made
the determination again of which aspects
of the data set our high value two must
be preserved helps to guide investments
in curation and subsequent to that
determining the high value data sets
will help us in understanding how to
ensure that those datasets become
discoverable knowable and reachable by
investigators who intend to use them
essentially a determination high value
data sets leads us to being able to
preserve with a purpose there is no
point in preserving every single data
element every generated in research but
we do need to be able to make
preservation decisions that are useful
to the community of discovery driven
research as well as useful to the public
as a whole so our preservation has to
consider for example how likely is it
did is set to be reused is it going to
be reused by a small community of people
who are well familiar with the data set
or is it a larger community that will
have it won't have interest in access in
that data set we need to use the
preservation strategy strategy to decide
the nature of metadata that gets
attached to data sets what type of
storage resource should it be a closed
and easily accessible online or is it
take backup safe storage use acceptable
for a particular data set finally the
preservation helps us know how to market
the existence and the availability of
the data sets we talk a lot about
metadata metadata being the process of
attaching information to a data set and
to the data elements within a data set
we believe that using standard
approaches to these is a is the only way
to ensure the findability of the data
sets and yet generating standards is a
is a complex and test that needs to be
undertaken in a systematic fashion we
see a lot of interest in the biological
communities about community driven
standards which are a reasonable
starting point but as you see with the
list of standards across the bar in the
center of this the kinds of standards
we've used in clinical data management
have been the result of balancing
individual unique communities like being
a laboratory community sno-med CT being
the clinical care community with the
other potential users participants in
this in the data use rxnorm for example
is a merger of data standards for
medications that draw both from the
pharmaceutical companies as well as from
the clinical care facilities we believe
the National Library of Medicine has a
process in place in the history of
developing standards and can serve as
both as a clearinghouse and as an
integrator of standards we don't make
the standards but we make the standards
accessible another aspect that the
National Library of Medicine is keenly
aware that we need to invest in across
lal of NH is generating new tools for
discovery and analysis the methodologies
that we have now some are very
specifically tied to a specific data set
or a specific domain where the
discoveries occurred we're looking to
develop both deeply tied to an
analytical method CETIS analytical
methods that are unique to particular
areas as well as broad-based ones so we
can get efficiencies across our
environments we see a great need for
promoting training this this session is
but one of the approaches to training
development that needs to be brought
forward to it as to the society training
we see it addressing three different key
groups the first our basic data
scientists these are the new algorithm
developers the new methodological
developers the second type of training
we need our data sophisticated
investigators domain-specific
investigators who have the knowledge and
the insights of how to work with data
science and data scientists to enhance
the discoveries in their area and
finally we need data informed front-end
workers with a clinician
or librarians or even patients who are
able to understand access and make use
of the products of data driven science
data-driven science doesn't happen alone
and it's not only going to happen within
just it can't happen only within the NIH
funded community but it needs to be done
in partnership across the federal
government across the international
borders and we work very closely with
the Wellcome Trust with ga4gh and a
number of groups that are advancing
standards and policies around data
sharing
we recognize that data does not no
country boundaries does not recognize in
scientists not held by a single country
the international efforts that the
National Library of Medicine has been
engaged in for years will help guide us
in the engagement with our international
partners to ensure free-flowing data and
information around the world I want to
pause for just a minute to remind you
that the endpoint of data science is the
health of individuals in our society and
whether they be an investigator such as
the woman on the left or a clinician the
gentleman on the right or a patient we
have an ultimate end user and while I
don't expect every single scientist and
every data scientists to have an
outreach component of their work that
ensures that the everyday layperson
understands and benefits from their work
I do believe that is a responsibility of
the NIH to make sure that our resources
and our discoveries are accessible and
known and useful to an extremely broad
range of individuals including the very
moment of care at the end-user place let
me close by talking a little bit about
where we're going next with the
integration with bd2k and the
investments in new to new data science
tools in the short run in the next few
years at NIH the beauty 2k program has
been quite a success developing new
methods giving us experience with
testing out moving of datasets
integration of datasets and we will
continue to build with them the program
the bd2k program has moved to the Common
Fund within our division of program
planning and evaluation and the bd2k
program investigators continue to meet
in our organized through that
dr. Betsy Wilders office there in the
common fund the activities that the bd2k
program is supporting right at this time
from January of 17 until August of
through August of 18 is to synthesize
and collect learnings from the centers
of excellence of which there were 12 to
conduct the Commons pilots now this
program name in the last weeks has
changed to the vanguard within the
Vanguard what was originally known as
the Commons pilots three high-value data
sets top meant gtex and the mods will be
or have been identified and will be
prepared for storage in a common
structure that will be a cloud-based
structure the plan is to establish a
foundation for authentication
authorization and curation that is
scalable but specifically gives us
experience with taking high-value data
sets and moving them into a cloud
environment there will be and much
attention giving to the cost of managing
data and moving data to a cloud
environment to make it more accessible
make it more reusable and interoperable
and also the experience of investigators
and their investigator teams of the
institutions both in terms of data
deposit as well as in terms of actually
using and operating on the data we
expect also to be stimulating new
inquiry in this area and again releasing
some releasing at least one funding
announcement to specifically conduct
analysis on two or more of these
high-value data sets top menu text for
example or the mods there will be a new
funding opportunity - a new funding
opportunity released this summer before
the end of fiscal 17 which will be done
under our other transactions Authority
so it won't be as straight it won't be a
research based grant but we're looking
for partnerships to develop the
authentication and authorization
strategies to establish a curation
approach and also to help with the
logistics of making transitions to cloud
environments feasible for more people
there will also there continues to be
investment in training our bd2k t32
program
continuing and as I indicated earlier
there is an investment in curation all
of these are have been I currently
funded our extensions into new programs
awaits fiscal 18 when I expect to see
new funding announcements come forward
we are though except emphasizing our
development of the infrastructure on the
NIH campus in front of you is a picture
of most of the campus but one of our big
buildings to the right is missing that
funny diamond-shaped building with the
diamond-shaped table and that's the
National Library of Medicine we're right
at the front edge of the campus we will
be building the Commons framework as is
depicted here and this is from Warren
Kitty and Billy and velocities work up
to get you to understand that what we
believe we're building at NIH is a
compute platform that will be managed
through commercial cloud services we
will be putting in place doc arises
containers for creating packaging of
applications and developing a digital
object identifier process test it out
first with these three high-value data
sets we are going to be integrating some
of the api's that were developed under
the bb2k program and developing new ones
and also enhancing the search process
and served for discoverability and
findability at the national
international library of medicine we are
also involved in moving data science
into our portfolio we are in the process
of partnering with groups to work on
creating the Emeka the mechanism to
determine high-value data sets and fort
and creating specifically forecasting
cost and utilization is the emphasis of
the program we're doing here we will be
implementing efficient secure and secure
preservation strategies that facilitate
access and reuse beginning in December
of this year we will be opening the
PubMed Central to allow data deposit
with articles that as they are entered
into PubMed that will be our first step
at opening a secure preservation
strategy that makes it accessible
through individual articles we will be
continuing to stimulate intramural
efforts and standards development and
try to bring some order of organization
to the
whose processes developing new methods
for data management and data-driven
discovery our methodological discoveries
our folks are emphasizing in the natural
language processing area and in machine
learning specifically for the short row
our Workforce Investment continues we
have many of our NLM training programs
now have added a data science dimension
we anticipate opening a new data
management training program in the
future that ended in the t32 and perhaps
a f31 mechanism we continue to engage
across the government particularly with
NSF and with NOAA to look at safe and
efficient strategies for data management
and storage and hope to be expanding
this and would we be excited through
through collaborations with others
finally we are doing all of this under a
concept of fostering of the idea of open
science of making science accessible to
the community to ensure that the process
from discovery from initial inception of
what what research ideas are interesting
to pursue to what research should be
pursued what the funding should be done
to actually opening and to actually
interpreting and disseminating
information being done in a way that
actually brings more openness engaging
industry engaging science society and
also engaging the individuals who have
the ability to lead in a scientific
workforce development finally they
realize we are absolutely committed to
making sure that the findings from the
bd2k program are in the cloud pilots the
Vanguard program now are made available
and accessible to as broad of a
community as possible
a key aspect of this for our work here
is going to be the establishment of a
structure for the development of data
science infrastructure at NIH and I
deliberately selected this image of the
series of blocks because what I envision
in the future is we will have a highly
distributed data structure our data
Commons at NIH will be but one of the
Commons is where data will be residing
in the future and our goals for
developing this and our goals for making
sure data are
accessible and knowable across a large
community require us to have in place a
stable structure that guides the
acquisition ingestion development and
and distribution of data as it goes
forward
I envision there will be in a division
with the National Library of Medicine
that focuses specifically on data
science and it will partner with our
data science investigators around the
NIH both in the intramural and the
extramural programs I also envision that
their resources that are already in
place in the National Library of
Medicine will help us reach the public
better so our community of the national
networks of libraries of medicine which
provide us with 6,500 points of presence
around the country will have in place
libraries and library resources that can
assist institutions and universities and
investigators to develop effective
methods for working with data
increasingly in our academic health
science centers we're seeing that our
librarians are taking a key role in
helping investigators prepare their data
for deposit and also to identify and
locate and manage large datasets much
the same way that we did the literature
so the librarians aren't going to do the
data science the same way that
librarians didn't do the basic science
that created the articles that grew out
of investigations but instead they're
going to provide it the facilitation the
information infrastructure for science
we believe also through the National ID
network of libraries of medicine that we
will be able to help the general public
better understand well data-driven
discoveries affect their lives for
example participants in the all of us
program which intends to obtain
biological samples as well as as other
types of assessments from over a million
people well it will be best served if
there's a library in the community that
can help people understand what it means
when one gets an individual test result
back from or an individual genetic
profile back through the all of us
program having trusted information
resources that are so able to support
the data-driven enterprise is both the
endpoint of the data driven discovery
process as well as a service that we
believe the government can provide I
will leave you now with just
one announcement that you may have heard
before but an important leader in the
data science initiative at NIH will be
leaving us dr. David Lipman the founding
director of the NCBI is going to be
stepping down next week after almost 30
years of service to NIH he greatly
improved their access to biomedical
information and genomic information his
discoveries of blast his standing up or
the DB gap and his critical important
offerings from the National Library of
Medicine and the NIH dr. Littman
making a major career change he's going
to be assuming the position of the chief
science officer at impossible foods
which is a a new company in California
that's applying molecular biology to the
food industry to create vegan based
foods we wish dr. Littman his great
success but recognize that many of the
comments that I made today and mention
the vision of data science at NIH was
shaped by this brilliant colleague and I
am grateful for his work I'll close by
robux got one more picture I'm sorry dr.
Littman was around at the very beginning
of the the development of the NCBI you
see him here with Claude pepper and dr.
members and as he is is showing as they
were discussing the launch of NCBI
before it became what it is today which
was a great an incredible resource for
data and I close by now showing you you
can reach me in many ways through a blog
called musings at the mezzanine which
focuses on the National Library of
Medicine resources another blog called
data science at NIH which focuses on our
data science activities here I'm on
Twitter and pretty active and I'm also
available by email I now I hope I've
given us enough time to have some
conversation about the directions for
the future and I welcome your thoughts
and your ideas thanks very much dr.
Brennan thank you so much for that's a
wonderful overview of data science from
the NIH it seems very comprehensive and
a lot of thought seems to have gone into
what the future of data science is going
to be at the NIH I'm moving forward
there are a number of questions as you
might imagine from a comprehensive talk
like yours and let me see if I can I
probably can't get to all of them but
per year
estee will try and copy all of them and
I'll forward them to you so that you can
kind of get a sense of the the things
that people are curious about but I'll
sample a few and maybe you can address
them I know that there was a lot of
discussion about the Commons and about
the role that that's going to play and
there were some questions about the role
of existing kind of data sharing efforts
that are being done through the NIH for
example like the National Cancer
Institute's genomics data Commons I know
there's some work that was spearheaded
formerly by dr. Insel at the NIH for
example the autism Centers of Excellence
where you're expected to provide your
data as a condition of your funding to
the national database of autism research
and other programs how will those play a
role will they benefit will they become
partners in the new data Commons how do
you see that working well I'm going to
take you back to my hope it will take
you back to my slide too to show you
that the structure that we envision is
if you will highly distributed structure
so the NIH data Commons will be but one
of what we envision as a whole network
of Commons and data repositories around
the world and our challenge is in
creating proper discovery mechanisms
catalogs for example it's not that it's
not dissimilar to the challenge that was
originally faced when the world wide web
in the domain name servers had to come
about so we were at the beginning of
needing to be able to locate and share
at the level of repositories and then at
the level of data sets we envisioned
that we work very closely with more
incoming and the cancer genome Commons
and also with the brain initiative with
the autism Commons and we do not see
those as being in any way closed by this
process by creating an NIH data comes
but rather the NIH data Commons is is
yet another participant in this activity
of data sharing now I will say that at
this point in time all of the focus in
developing the NIH Commons is targeted
around known data set
and we see going forward that the models
for curating known datasets might be
slightly different than the models for
curating new datasets and again we're
working with a trans-nih group to make
sure that we first of all don't don't
tie ourselves to an archiving model that
actually isn't as robust as the future
will need but second so that we don't
lose our connections to those models let
me say just briefly we expect that we
will be connecting the data Commons
infrastructure will connect to data
Commons our data other data repositories
held in different places including
within universities including at
research institutes and in other
countries the negotiation of what
constitutes access exchange what kinds
of compute resources are going to be
available will will I believe make make
for a substantial amount of conversation
as well as as indexing of resources over
the next few years we're at an early
stage of this we we fundamentally
believe a distributed structure is
essential when one makes a commitment to
a distributed structure what makes a
commitment to invest in discovery tools
as much as analytic tools that was
another series of questions had to do
with the role of tools and even though
the Commons is being constructed now at
the NIH itself will there be op do you
envision future opportunities for people
who develop tools which leverage the
Commons and the data in it and its
metadata as part of new some of your new
funding initiatives that you see on the
horizon absolutely I'm quite committed
to methods to accelerating methods
development at which which is necessary
necessary precursor to accelerating
knowledge development I believe we are
considering for example what does a
library of models look like how do we
how do we curate models the way we've
curated the literature so the models
become so an executable version of a
model becomes accessible and knowable we
also so in so we anticipate that we're
going to have to invest in three areas
with respect to
models first of course model model
development and we worked with the inter
government modeling and analysis and
simulation group on the beginning parts
of the step but in addition we know we
need to find a way to distribute models
more effectively than in text narrative
of an article or as an appendage to an
article so we are looking to find a
mechanism for create constructing model
libraries libraries of discoverable
models of libraries and finally we need
to find ways that where we can
efficiently link models and data sets in
a way that allows for allows them to be
interrogated but isn't it isn't terribly
redundant or complex in its organization
and by that I mean that as a model is
modified for a particular data set it is
really important to be able to recover
that exact instance of the model with
that data set if one wants to try to
reproduce a set of findings and we have
the way we do this in the literature
right now is we have a citation database
with investigators describe their
background or place their work in a
certain scientific tradition and then
use text to describe the procedures they
will be doing for there they're there to
carry out an experiment or that they did
use to carry out an experiment as we
move into data-driven discovery we need
to be thinking about different ways of
documenting the scientific process as
well as archiving that documentation so
I see a whole range of new scientific
communication tools emerging along with
the discovery tools and the analytical
tools it was very interesting that you
meant it you mentioned libraries one of
the things that at least I have learned
through our running of these data
science seminar series is the interest
and potential source of energy if you
will that comes from librarians and
library scientists and their potential
role here and we had a question from
someone asking will the National Library
of Medicine be hiring additional
librarians who have data science kind of
experience following a trend across the
country apparently this is a great
question it would surprise and that
maybe not
would certainly suppress me when I first
came here last summer that we have 1700
men and women that work here at the
National Library of Medicine and we only
have 97 librarians which tells you that
the work of a library takes a lot of
different disciplines together not not
the least of which is librarians we do
anticipate that that we will be that our
library operations group which manages
the the collection that we have as what
do we physically own as well as the
curation our MedlinePlus excuse me our
MEDLINE literature citation process will
be enriched with with individuals who
will be helping with the data the data
curation process what we expect to have
happen and I anticipated the development
of something that might look like a
PubMed for data now people here don't
want me to say it quite that way because
it's not a direct equivalent but just as
we have a journal archive tagging system
jazz system we are in the process of
working with the bio caddy group to
refine the DAX DAT s which is a data
archiving tagging system so we will be
able to to put a high-level metadata
structure that Ola enable us to
catalogue data that will require that we
use the library science skills in
cataloging and creating indexing so
individuals can find the data sets and
just as we don't hold every article that
is listed in MEDLINE we would not hold
that is be the owner of every data set
that is listed in a data catalog but
rather provide the pathway to it I say
librarians as having two other really
key roles library science librarians
isn't brought into research project from
the very beginning can help the research
team describe the data management plan
in a way that addresses sustainability
and ensures that meant that that that
the metadata even the early generation
can occur as data is being acquired not
not simply weighted so the data set is
complete and the second aspect is that
our library science community is going
to be a great assistance to our
investigators and frankly to the public
in general small businesses
industry in actually locating datasets
because the process of searching for
datasets and locating them is slightly
it's not it's not nearly as as refined
as this process of searching for the
literature so we'll need all the library
science technical talent we can get
that's probably going to be good news to
a number of people you mentioned data
sharing plans and I know that the NIH
has been very interested in increasing
the description of how people will be
sharing their data across a variety of
grants typically these have been at the
more expensive end of the grant spectrum
if you will but this increasingly I
suspected that it's going to be coming
down to our o ones and our 21s etcetera
how does the Commons play into that or
inform that policy of what could be what
can be shared and when it can be shared
under the kind of grant mechanism
framework so this is a very good
question and some of you may be familiar
with the the the rather strong
separation between intramural and
extramural research at the NIH but in
the data science particularly the data
sharing process those two areas get
blended quite quickly we envision that
that that publicly funded research and
the data derivative generated through
publicly funded research should be
available to the public that's an open
science framework so having said that we
need to find ways to help investigators
in an efficient way be able to make
their data shareable and that is the
basis underlying the idea of the Commons
there will be a safe place for the data
to reside now if we start thinking about
that 18,000 NIH funded projects that are
going on and disagree on this very day
that's a lot of different datasets to
archive and to anything there will they
will continue to be growing so we would
expect that there will be that not so
much from the Commons but from our to
our office of science policy and through
our materials in the funding
announcements and in the cost and the
guides we will have a tent there will be
guidance regarding how to prepare a data
set for
as and how to determine which parts of a
dataset need to be shared how to
identify that an acceptable storage
opportunity for data set because we
don't envision ever requiring that all
data generated in all NIH projects be
only stored at the NIH but rather that
we foster the use of appropriate types
of archiving for the data appropriate
types of discoverability I must comment
for just a moment on the idea of what we
call the accession aim datasets when a
dataset is no longer actively used or
actively in need we need to have
policies in place that describe what
happens next
does it go to a lower long-term storage
environment does it remain in an index
do we need to do we need to retain all
of the modeling that was done with the
data set to ensure that it can continue
to be used those questions now are going
to require extensive comments from the
community as well as proposed as plans
developed here at the NIH that's great
one question is sort of this is sort of
a two-pronged question if you'll indulge
me for a second but we've got a number
of questions about this I'm trying to
synthesize I just personally I always
think you mentioned the fair principles
and we don't need to go into what they
all mean but I've always kind of
secretly felt that there's a silent E on
the end of fair that you don't hear that
Easton's for education and training and
that the role of education and training
and data science is absolutely
fundamental to not only helping people
who are not biomedical scientists but
from statisticians and computer
scientists get into looking at these
very rich sources of data I want to hear
a little bit more about what you feel
the role of Education will be but also
how that touches on the role of Trust
which you also mention in terms of
public outreach I think now we're about
two three weeks after the March for
science and the notion of
trustworthiness and science and maybe
some distrust from certain you know
portions of the the American population
I think that's an important role and I
want to hear what your thoughts are on
well you don't become a data scientist
at the PhD level you have
to begin thinking about data science
from the k-12 experience so we are
partnering with the NSF to look at how
we can influence and strengthening the
foundation for data science in the k-12
education program children who are
exposed to probability theory and fourth
graders some nuances about algebra by
the time they're in the sixth grade will
do much better in the future and we will
be able to concentrate our University
based data science training with its
substrate of individuals I start
building on the substrate of knowledge
that individuals bring at that moment
but we do we also have to think about
the generations of investigators and
analysts and librarians and clinicians
who are in their 30s 40s and 50s who
grew up with experimental models of
knowledge building and evidence
generation and need to move over into
complement that not not replace a
completely the complement with data
science so I would envision that we will
have that there are future training
nih-funded training will include early
career mid-career opportunities for
investigators to get deeper training in
the data sciences we expect to be
partnering with the Medical Library
Association and with our library
colleagues through the association of
research libraries to build effective in
the moment training for our workers who
need to have access to understanding
about data science and where it fits
into the process of inquiry but don't
have the ability to leave to get another
degree that's created did you have any
final thoughts on public outreach and
with how the data science Commons might
help with that well I I believe that our
ability to be transparent and I'm just
demonstrating why scientific conclusions
are ours and the pathways from which
they arose will enhance the public trust
I believe that the National Library of
Medicine in particular in the NIH in
general enjoys a great deal of the
public trust and so the strategies that
we take to make data accessible not only
through the scientific channels but also
through public libraries is an important
part of how we will be engendering trust
from the public at the same time we have
to help
public developed numeracy literacy and
an understanding of probabilistic and
thinking because not not at the same
depth of an investigator but we need to
move from a society that largely views
points as truisms to understanding
ranges and pathways and patterns so that
we don't oversell the result that a
particular study or a particular
investigation provides and again the
idea of building a quantitative ly a
sophisticated public will require us
engaging in the very earliest levels
well with that I'd like to thank you so
much dr. Brennan for that wonderful
overview of NIH data science thinking a
pathway forward and and some of the
details about how you envision that
happening I think this was outstanding
in an outstanding way to end our series
of data science seminars through funded
through the bd2k program which have been
just so wonderfully attended and so I
want to thank all of our attendees for
their participation and any feedback
that you have will be what welcomes to
to receive that so once again thank you
so much and thank you dr. Brennan thank
you John and I'll comment on some of the
items in my blog if it's possible to do
so so keep watching thank you okay thank
you so much thank you everybody